that is not true at all those people can
mind their own business and
if you have a job then you have a job if
you don't have a job it's not because of
me
it's i can i can assure you of that
hello everybody my name is nyan i'm the
black female engineer i provide content
for you an aspiring software engineers
and today
we are going over y'all's questions i'll
be answering questions 10 of y'all
had for me about coding bootcamp jobs
and interviews and
whatnot and so yeah we're gonna get
right to it but
please if you see anything in the
background i just moved and so
things are everywhere so if you see
something in the background just remind
your business
but no let's get into it so the first
question comes from jordan
thomas i'm gonna be looking down on my
laptop and jordan thomas
asks as someone who is currently
enrolled in flatiron
i'm just curious what was the hardest
concept for you to grasp
something that you may still not have
down a hundred percent yet
and may have a mild panic attack
whenever you are forced
to work with it mine would definitely
be react it took me a long
time for me to feel like i finally
grasped it
enough and really was because of the
flow
react has in development it's very
powerful it's great for large
teams and there are so many benefits to
it
however when it came to my brain it took
longer for me to understand that flow of
things
and so that did just slow me down a lot
you mentioned here
that you're having trouble with
javascript javascript
did trip me up a lot when i was first
learning specifically with
dealing with on click um functions and
rendering things onto the screen and
making things persist
oh my goodness that was really really my
biggest struggle when i was learning
javascript the like just the vanilla
javascript
and really what i recommend is doing
building burns that's what i did
always till sunday i would look up the
lectures that my
instructors posted and you said you're
in finance school i
imagine your instructors post the
lectures they do or the recordings
and i would look at them and build along
and then i would demolish it all down
and then try again without looking at
anything see how far i got
and really this would help me see really
what part of my struggle
um like why i'm struggling with things
and what part of the things i'm
struggling with
rather than saying oh javascript is hard
being able to say oh it's hard for me to
render things
properly onto a page and because that
was the part that would always stop
at and so that's something i really
really recommend and hopefully this
helps the next question comes from aaron
nostradna
and they asked you posted a video a few
weeks ago calling out the interview
process for asking very technical and
very advanced questions
to candidates seeking entry-level
developer
positions why do you think this happens
i personally think
that it happens because large companies
like the
you know the fame companies like the
facebooks the
googles they had
created this technical interview that's
so advanced
so large because you know their
companies are so advanced and so large
and so they created that but i feel like
it ended up
trickling down to now mid-sized
companies and small
companies because it became this
i don't even know it became this like
show
of like machoness and this show of
advancement and wow we're so great and
let's see if we can get past this level
and so that was kind of the gatekeeping
mechanism
that these top companies had and so now
middle mid size and small companies i
feel like wanted that same
oomph to them that same type of
exclusivity
um that those companies had
and so they start adopting more
difficult
technical interview processes as well
and your question here you mentioned
that you think it's because
they want to hire a more advanced person
for entry-level roles that way they have
more of like
a mid-level person but paying them a
very beginner salary as a really good
thought
i don't i'm sure it happens but i don't
imagine that's the reason why
widespread that these companies are
giving really hard technical interviews
because
there is no shortage of developer roles
in this country especially now there's
no shortage
and they are willing to pay top dollar
for them and so
if you're a developer who ends up in a
role like this where
they're paying you nothing to employ
these major
type roles even though you're an entry
level
well you would just leave you know what
i mean you would just leave
and then the company is back to
recruiting and recruiting is not cheap
y'all
recruiting is expensive and so
i don't imagine that's the overarching
reason just because
there's so many jobs out there that will
pay you
the fair wage that the company at the
end of it would be the losers of the
situation
not the developer not the worker and so
i can't imagine that that's the
overarching reason and i can't imagine
my reason is the overarching reason
either to be complete like
this is just my thought process a study
came out showing that
if you gave these fang interviewers
the problem that they're giving you they
too would not be able to solve it
without
hard preparation beforehand now i'm not
saying don't prepare i'm not saying
don't prepare
but just to give you some minds
like just to give you some insight into
the whole interviewing and show you how
hard it is where even if you
worked there and were on these teams or
on these projects you still
wouldn't be able to solve these problems
without months and months of preparation
and so i definitely believe the
technical interview process really needs
a reboot and a revamp more and more
companies have kind of
gone away with this because at the end
of the day i can teach you
how to write an if statement but i can't
teach you to be a person i want to work
with to be a good employee
to be a person that contributes
positively to
this you know workspace and so more and
more companies are getting away with
are getting giving way um and just
not paying too much mine to technical
interviews now
but no it is not no no
no next question comes from gigi who
asks
i looked up grants to attend boot camps
and only
found um limited choices like flatiron
only tuesdays
offer grants for women i would love you
to talk more on how to get
grants so that's interesting that when
you looked up grants from finance only
two states showed up um and i imagine
you're
you mentioned that because you know that
i got a grant to attend flatiron i
i received i think it was a three
thousand dollar grant last
year to attend flat-out school i did not
know this was not a widespread
grant um it was only available in a few
campuses
however flat iron now just launched a
campaign
where they are offering the women take
tech
grants and so it's available for anyone
identifying as a woman looking to
get into flatter for either software
engineering or data analysis or
they have so much y'all they have cyber
security they have now trying to go off
memory they have cyber security they
have
usui developments they have so so
many options the grant is for up to
three thousand
dollars and so hopefully now i know you
wrote this question before the campaign
launched and so hopefully with that you
can get some ease and whatnot i'll
provide a link in my description box
below so that you can go straight to
learn more about the campaign and the
grant and really all you do is apply you
then will get your voice that
you want to receive that grant you want
some
money to get you through this because
y'all is not cheap it is that cheap
so hopefully that helps you out but in
general
i highly recommend just googling in
general seeing
okay what companies what organizations
are willing to sponsor me to go through
coding boot camp searching yeah coding
boot camp grants
for women coding boot camp sponsorships
for people of color for women of color
for
the lgbtq community sometimes a little
bit more research
is needed to really really find um the
right
grants and sponsorships and scholarships
for you but hopefully
some weight is taken off your shoulder
when you go to the description box
go see my link and you get to learn
about the grant they're currently
offering nationwide next question is
from michelle
wesson who asks did flatiron offer you
any assistance
finding your first job do they help you
get interviews
so i'm going to answer the question in
two
parts so flat iron definitely helps you
in your getting a job journey after you
complete your 15 weeks of learning
you then are moved on to the more
career-minded um
like group they have a whole career
section division i can't think of the
correct term
but they have people whose job it is to
be your counselor
and help you get to that job it's not
just
your instructor giving you advice after
hours like no it's a
legit division that you get to
have weekly meetings and go through tech
mock interviews go through behavioral
lock interviews they review your resume
and all of these different checklist
items they really do so much to help
however with me if you are familiar
with my journey i started applying to
jobs a solid six weeks after starting
coding boot camp
and so by the time i graduated and was
moved to the career
division of things i already was like
i almost had my third interview for some
positions
so and then i believe about a week or
two weeks later i had signed on an
offer so they didn't help
me because they didn't have the
opportunity to help me i had already
like been like no this is the way i am
doing this one two three
and i was able to get a job i was able
to actually get my first job offer
on my graduation day and so
no they didn't help me because i didn't
give them the chance to
however they have a whole division like
i said
aimed at helping you and one reason i
chose flatiron
this is important to note is because
they
have such a robust partnership um
partnerships with other companies where
if you tell them i'm looking for
front-end developer roles at
a mid-sized company they'll be able to
steer you in some type of direction
and hopefully even connect you with
those people or
be able to now when they hear of a job
opening up or a physician opening up
they will contact you i remember my
counselor would email me directly like
yo you said you are x y and z well here
you go
and then i responded sorry girl i forgot
to tell you i got a job
but they do that and so that's something
that
i love with flat and watch ultimately
made me
made the decision for me because
learning how to code is great but what
good is it
if you don't get a job afterwards and so
yes they definitely do help and they
really really
put the time in for you next question
comes from chai
n who asks do you network within your
field if so
how what is your favorite way of
networking has it ever helped you land a
job
so i'm quite an introvert i'm quite the
introvert
and so there have been many
opportunities for me to network
with like slack groups and different
channels um
and happy hours and virtual happy hours
because you know this whole
parent-teacher conference is
still among us and so there
are opportunities too and is highly
recommended i personally
have been like lacking have been
slacking
in this i i plan to get better
i'll take this question as a sign for me
to do better
but i highly recommend networking to get
jobs in general
i what i did when i was looking for a
job was every time i found a job that i
liked i would go on linkedin and find
someone in
that company to talk to and i would just
do a cold call basically where i'll just
blindly message them
ask for a few minutes of their time and
we would just talk about the position
and i would ask
them questions and so that was my way of
networking but that was when i was
looking for a job
and it's great to network when you don't
need a job
because when you do need a job you've
already formed these
robust connections with your with the
people around you the people in your
field
because people can see right through it
when
you're just networking because you need
your bills paid like people can see
through that and they're
i don't think they're they'd be more
less willing to help but
it's just less fun because it's like
okay will this person
just dip after they get the job and so
it's better to
network when you don't need it that way
when you do need it
you haven't you have those relationships
and so no i highly recommend slack
channels
i remember my um city had like
a deaf community for that city and so
look those up also facebook groups are
fantastic
look up yeah software developer in
minneapolis or
wherever you are or you know people of
color and tech or things like that
and see what facebook's facebook groups
you can join
and be active be ask for one-on-one
meetings
ask for advice and help and for people
to just drink calls and whenever
you have the opportunity to join a call
or join a virtual happy hour or go to a
conference
really really take that opportunity
because
a person's network especially in this
field can really be
everything chai and you also ask if you
could choose another
area or field of tech which one would
you choose for a career
i personally would choose
a i i think that
is such an interesting tech realm
and when we look at the history of a.i
it's very much been dominated by
one type of person one type of
developer and so i think
it would be great to have a voice
in that because when there's not
a large pool of diverse mindsets
going into something problems arise
y'all you can see
that a little bit ago i actually read a
study
that showed how self-driving cars are
less likely to identify
people of color in the streets
a car cannot identify
me not cannot but is less it's harder
for it
to identify that is a problem that's a
life or death
problem sometimes people can see
diversity in the workplace everything
tech as like
oh because it's like the right thing to
do and
oh it's because like we're trying to be
good people like no
it's because it can create life or death
situations having diversity
in the workplace because if we had a
person of color
part of these decisions part of these
different things then they would think
about
that they would i would think that
they would say you know what would be
nice if the car saw me
walking down the street so it didn't hit
me i think
that yeah so that's what i have to say
about that
if you'd like to know more about this i
highly recommend watching coded bias
on netflix it's an amazing movie that
really goes
into this topic going into the studies
that have been done
and really the widespread implications
um of a lack of diversity in the
ai realm so i really recommend that
but no that's really why i would be a
part of it to kind of
also just fix it from the inside you
know
um being this you know like trojan horse
just going in
then you know let's let's fix this
and so yeah that definitely would be the
field
i would be in one i and desmond ray
asked what are the top three things to
do before entering coding bootcamp
one is to identify each and every
stressor in your life no matter how big
no matter how small is it your job is it
your man's is it your parents is it your
child crying in the background
identify every single stressor in your
life and then figure out a solution for
each of them is it is it your job okay
can you
work for the next x amount of months
really save
up and then quit so that when you get
your coding bootcamp you can just focus
on community bootcamp
is it your baby can you talk to your
partner
and or your family members and ask okay
from these hours these hours can you be
the sole
caretaker so that i can focus on my
education
if it's your man's can you break up with
can you bring up with them i i mean like
i'm
i'm half kidding but truly that is also
an important consideration i think many
of us
can attest to the um
what you'll call it the damage that
being in a relationship with a person
who is not
not supportive of you and your goals and
you only
add stress even the best of times
how that um that's not the best place to
be in
no matter what and so now think about
your future goals including boot camp
and everything
maybe shoot maybe it's time to split
fast i don't know
but no truly seriously see
what stressors you have in your life
literally no matter how big my how
small and formulate a plan to resolve
each of them so that's number one
because with coding bootcamp
it's really stressful like i
had like the things i did to make sure
that i could succeed
um pat and get a job after returning
boot camp and have
the most seamless transition possible
and still it wasn't a seamless
transition still it's hard
and it's intense and it's so so
emotional
but i moved in with my parents so that i
wouldn't have to worry about bills or
feeding myself or rent i reached out to
my friend saying hey for the next like
three to four months you may not hear
from me and so like please don't take it
personally but
i'm in the zone so please like i'm sorry
and so i truly took that seriously and
so i'm saying like really take that
seriously write that list
and figure out um plans for a resolution
for each of them
so that's number one that's the biggest
thing for me to be honest once you have
this i think you're
in a pretty good spot i can't even can i
think of two more
things two contact your friends and
family tell them
the journey you're about to embark on um
and that you would like
their support and thanking them for um
yeah the future support that they'll be
giving you
and three
three establish a solid linkedin
account um that way you're not doing it
while you're at boot camp because while
you're at bootcamp you want to keep
updating your status and your projects
on linkedin because so many people can
see that and linkedin
like sure maybe none of your connections
are developers
but their connections might be and their
connections might be
and so it's a great way to like get your
projects and portfolio
out there and for more people to see
that no you're serious about this
and seeing ways to assist you on that
path
so yes make your list contact friends
and family and create
a robust linkedin account so that once
you do start
you post regularly about the projects
you've built
and um yeah just keeping people updated
on your journeys that when you do start
looking for a job
then there's this because recruiters
look at linkedin
also not just github not just your
resume they also look at linkedin
and so when you do start looking for a
job they go to your linkedin and see all
the things you've already done
or people connect with you based on
based on you wanting to be in this field
you also ask explain some of the tickets
or requests you would have
to do at your job really
tickets came down to two things bug
fixes
and enhancing the current apps
and correct me if i'm wrong i imagine
that's what most
tickets would be for any developer um
outside of the oh do this type of
managerial task
if we're talking tech focus i imagine
there would all be bug fixes or
enhancements
bug fixes so hey when people try to
add things to their shopping cart the
number
that appears on the shopping cart isn't
the right number
of things that are actually in their
cart and so
bug fixes or saying hey let's start
adding this type of carousel banner to
the home
page that displays five products at a
time
and i want it done by monday and so yeah
enhancements
or bug fixes and these two examples are
examples of tickets i actually did go
through when
i was working in congress cloud
development now however i'm in a whole
new job i actually just finished day two
of orientation
and i'm actually filming the day i'm
going to be posting this and so
it really is day two of orientation for
me and
so soon i'll be sharing more about the
tickets i experienced and my work day
and what i do and so
that answer will change uh soon but the
overarching yeah
bug fixes and enhancement okay so next
question comes from
at mz underscore tommy who asked
before landing a job how much knowledge
of programming do i need to
have that's a hard question
what i will say is i did not have any
programming experience before coding
boot camp
i had self-taught for about a month and
a half to two months
and i was hired right at the end of my
coding bootcamp and so in
total it was about six months of
learning
um both self-taught and encoding boot
camps six months total
that i was learning
before i got hired and so i will say
coding bootcamp really did provide me
with all the skills necessary to at
least get a junior level
position to get a better understanding
of what skills you need
if you aren't looking to go to a coding
bootcamp bookcamper and are just trying
to be self-taught
i highly recommend looking up junior
developer positions
and taking note of the skill sets and
requirements
that are listed on each of the different
job postings and then
try to see if you see some type of
pattern in each of them
and that is a good way to know
what's expected for you to learn in
search of the wording say
yeah junior developer junior software
engineer front end developer backhand
developer full stack developer
entry level full stack developer things
like that switch up the wording because
sometimes
different things pop up for different
things even though
it's really the same title so yeah
switch it up and
see if you can see any type of pattern
next comes from
i think you pronounce it at kelly
achilles um who asked how perfect should
a portfolio
project be i i do go over
some of this in my previous videos where
i go over
the five portfolio projects to have and
also i go over my specific portfolio
projects the ones i had
on my resume to get to my job
and so i highly recommend you look at
those two but overall
if they have pretty you know good
crud functionalities i think that's
great crud stitch for create read update
delete so if it's a blog app can a
person create a new blog can a person
read something um that's already been
posted can a person
update a previous posting and they can
they delete
a posting they had uh the blog example
is really the best example for
the crud functionalities but if you
think about things like instagram
you can create a post you can read other
people's posts you can
update on your current posting like edit
it um and you can delete photos and
things like that
and so yeah do they have basic crud
functionalities
if they do then you're a pretty great
spot specifically for
junior level slash entry level positions
but i highly recommend you check out
those two videos i'll link them below
and above
so that you can yeah easily look at them
but overall it doesn't need to be
perfect but
you wanted to have those functionalities
and you also wanted to be pretty
i know so a lot of people kind of put
css
to the wayside because they're like oh
it's not important
it's not actual development and whatnot
and
well maybe it's not you know super
applicable to the jobs you want
but at the end of the day when people
are looking at your portfolio it sucks
but
we humans we judge books by they're
covered the whole reason
don't judge a book by its cover is a
saying is because
people do it you know what i mean people
have a problem with that and so
you want to make sure styling isn't the
reason that people
aren't bringing you into and for
interviews because this tiling threw
them off so much that
they didn't even bother with the rest of
the app and so
just make sure things are like packaged
nicely but don't focus too much on the
packaging
where functionalities and features
aren't there because
yeah it looks pretty but it does nothing
and so it's nice to have a good
balance at rambling mind show asks what
is one
thing that you've always wanted to do
that you can finally do
i imagine you mean like because of
my new career and for me
one thing that i can finally do to me
it's financial um security i know that's
maybe basic but it's a big thing for me
growing up for people who have known me
growing up
that was somewhat of a struggle
um or a fear i think is a better word um
the lack thereof and so
being able to be in a position where i'm
like wow i'm in a
new apartment and i just bought my first
car and i am planning trips and
vacations that's something i truly
don't take for granted or i try not to
take for granted
at all because i it really means a lot
to me
and so that is a big one for me i try
not to cry
but that's truly a big one for me and so
i'm really excited
to see how things develop for me as the
days weeks months and years go on and
then last question comes from ebony
nelson and girl okay there's a couple
there's a couple questions here
um so i'm gonna try to get through them
all but
your first question is is the market
desperate for developers right now or is
it flooded with developers
quick and easy answer yes they need
developers
the market is not flooded with
developers i know
for me when i was thinking about coding
boot camp that was a fear of mine that
shoot people keep saying that coding
boot camp grabs are just diluting the
market
and all of this that is not true at all
those people can mind their own business
and if you have a job then you have a
job if you don't have a job it's not
because of me
it's i can i can assure you of that um
and so
no don't if that's the reason why you
ask then no
don't give into this at all the market
is not
flooded with developers 2020 especially
made the market skyrocket with
developers actually wrote it down
and dave reported that there was a
growth in software developer roles of 22
where other roles were at a mere 4
and so no they need developers 2020
really made companies
invest more in technologies that would
allow people to do things like work from
home or
consumers to experience products from
home and all that jazz
and so with this big need now for
software
and good technology so many developers
were are needed
now more than ever so no like
get it girl i don't think that you won't
have a job because there's just all
these developers and whatnot no don't
think that
at all your next question is when you're
applying for jobs did you apply for jobs
that had a degree requirement and five
to ten years of experience
i'm asking because i was looking for
jobs this morning and i put myself in a
box
looking for entry level positions and
there were only 25 that were entry level
so i applied entry level yes but i also
applied to jobs
that would say like one to three years
of experience or two to three years of
experience
especially if i saw that these skills
and
qualifications noted other than the
years of experience
matched my skill set i think
that people especially women often
disqualify themselves before
anyone else gets the chance to i saw
this other stat that
was like and i i don't remember the
specific numbers the percep
the specific percentages so don't quote
me on them
but the idea was that men will apply to
a job
when they fit let's say 50 of the skill
sets
noted in the posting while women will
apply to a job
when they fit 80 or more percent of the
skill sets
noted and so like come on no
no and so at the end of the day i will
learn and so
if i am lucky enough to get an interview
for a job that requires more experience
than i have
i will not shy away from that topic i'll
say look i don't have
experience in mongodb but i'm so excited
to learn
look at how much i was able to learn in
such a more in such a short amount of
time
i am even more eager to learn this with
you all
and so no at the end of the day like i
said they can teach you
you know sql and mongodb and if
statements
they can't teach you to be a good person
and to be a hard worker
and so no don't let those qualifications
um trip you up from applying
at least apply you know at least apply
uh but what i will say is i did stop at
the three-year mark
whenever i asked for more than three
years that's when i kind of
cut it and so yeah focus more on the
skill sets needed and if you see that
they match
yours really well don't only apply but
make sure your resume very clearly shows
those skill sets so that
when they do go through it they see that
okay
so they don't have as much as many years
of experience we want but look at all
the technologies and all of the
qualifications they have as noted in
their resume
you also ask which websites did you use
looking for jobs
i typically used like just google.com i
would say
junior software engineer front-end
developer back in developer full stack
and
i would filter out um accordingly based
on the things i wanted because
when you do look through google itself
basically its own kind of portal pops up
and you can filter
out based on the things you want do you
want it to be
in milwaukee to be full time to be part
time etc and so
that's mostly what i did but what i also
did was i did make a list of about 20
companies that i really
love and would want to work for and so
after i made that list i went on the
company's actual
pages and went on to their career page
and
looked up positions that i might qualify
for
and so i did the two things i hear
indeed is great for applying to jobs i
never
use indeed but i do have friends and
family members
members that do and they really like
indeed as well they say it's very easy
and so i recommend checking that out as
well
and then your last question is do you
think it's better to finish your coding
bootcamp before applying to jobs
or is it better to wait until after boot
camp is done
i personally think it is better to start
applying before boot camp is over
as long as you have everything
adequately prepared like your resume
your linkedin your github
all of those things because when you
apply
there's like a solid two to six weeks
that you just don't hear anything back
even if you get an interview there's
solid weeks
that you're just sitting there turning
your thumbs and so
why in my mind why would you wait until
the end of boot camp
to experience that weight you know what
i mean i would rather
apply before i end boot camp and then
now for those two to four to six weeks
i'm still going through boot camp i'm
still applying to jobs and then by the
time boot camp is over
hopefully by then i start hearing back
about interviews and things like that
i did say that i did start applying
about six weeks after my boot camp
started
i don't know if i would run i would do
this again
what i will say is if you do do that
make sure you're not targeting companies
that are your like dream
job because odds are you're very new to
this
i was very new to this and so i didn't
even really
know what the lay of the land was and so
it's better to
if you do apply way early like that to
do companies that you kind of wouldn't
really cry to bed at night
if you didn't hear back from and just
to get that practicing of filling out
the applications and
interviewing and talking with people and
networking and whatnot
but in general i think it is great to
maybe start applying a couple of weeks
at least
before your boot camp ends that way yeah
when your boot camp ends
you're not just there waiting for the
jobs you just applied to
but there we go everybody our q a
session is over thank you so much to
everyone
who reached out who asked me questions
on instagram on youtube
make sure you do follow me on instagram
because i will um sometimes
answer questions just like on the fly
there and so
my instagram handle is at the black
female engineer make sure you follow me
make sure you like this video and
subscribe
if you liked it if you liked it but
thank you so much i'm so excited
to share more things with you soon i
told you
it's day two of orientation just ended
and so i'm
pumped for what's about to be shared and
whatnot
but no i hope you all have a great rest
of your day
and i'll see you all later bye